y llegó el momento de hablar de deportes
ya está listo conmigo en el estudio juan
pupiales juan feliz mañana de jueves
vamos a empezar entonces hablando de
esta cita que me encanta y digo los
juegos olímpicos de invierno pero hay
una polémica en torno a una patinadora
rusa juan que pasó estamos apenas en la
primera semana de estos juegos y ya
tenemos que saber la gran polémica de
beijing 2022 ahora mismo una sombra de
dudas sobre la nueva estrella del
patinaje artístico hablamos de la rosa
camila vale va de 15 años que deslumbró
al mundo el domingo al convertirse en la
primera mujer que completa un salto
cuádruple en unos juegos olímpicos en la
conquista del oro en la prueba por
equipos hay dos periódicos rusos rbc y
kommersant que aseguran que camila dio
positivo en un control previo al
comienzo de estas justas la rusa habría
dado positivo para three metas y dime
qué se utiliza para tratar las anginas o
el vértigo y que es una sustancia
prohibida por la agencia mundial
antidopaje porque aumenta la eficacia la
eficiencia del flujo sanguíneo y mejora
la resistencia desde el comité olímpico
internacional rechazaron a hablar sobre
el tema mientras que hoy camila
entrenando con normalidad como la vemos
porque el martes de ella tiene previsto
participar en la prueba individual como
decíamos camila ganó ya un oro en estos
juegos olímpicos pero la ceremonia de
entrega de medallas de esa prueba la de
equipos se ha aplazado por razones
legales dice la organización hay
entonces muchas dudas y más teniendo en
cuenta el reglamento de la agencia
mundial antidopaje que no permiten
publicar el nombre de un caso positivo
si se trata de una menor de edad raúl y
para añadir más polémica a este caso
adivina quién le ganó la prueba por
equipos el comité olímpico ruso en esa
prueba del domingo la verdad van no lo
sé la gana eeuu bueno vamos vamos a ver
sigue la polémica entonces vamos a ver
qué pasa